S
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET INTO, SO
LET'S DIVE RIGHT IN.
FULL STEAM BEHIND, THAT IS THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
BEFORE FLYING OFF TO EUROPE
TODAY, JOE BIDEN MADE A PERSONAL
MISSION TO CAPITOL HILL TO URGE
DEMOCRATS TO PASS A SO-CALLED
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
I DON'T THINK IT'S HYPERBOLE TO
SAY THAT THE WHITE HOUSE, THAT
THE HOUSE AND SENATE MAJORITIES
IN MY PRESIDENCY WILL BE
DETERMINED BY WHAT HAPPENS IN
THE NEXT WEEK.
I NEED YOU TO HELP ME, HE
SIGHED.
"I NEED YOUR VOTES."
HE PROBABLY DID THAT WEIRD
WHISPER THING.
PELOSI ECHOED HIS PLEA TELLING
HER MEMBERS, DON'T EMBARRASS THE
PRESIDENT BY VOTING DOWN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
REPORTEDLY, SOME MEMBERS
ACTUALLY BEGAN BREAKING OUT IN
CHANCE.
"A BOAT, VOTE."
BUT TO WHAT END?
>> I HAVE SIGNALED FOR DAYS THAT
WE SIMPLY DID NOT HAVE THE VOTES
FOR THE BIPARTISAN BILL WITHOUT
THE OTHER BILL, THE BILL -- OUR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN SEEN FOR
MONTHS THAT THESE TWO BILLS NEED
TO GO TOGETHER.
>> Laura: AND THAT IS WHAT
THEY ARE HOLDING OUT FOR.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE GRAND MADAM
NANCY PELOSI WAS HERSELF WHIPPED
BY THE SQUAD.
SPEAK OF THE HOUSE SPEAKER AND
PRESIDENT RAISED THE STAKES AND
IT DIDN'T WORK.
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THE PRESIDENT LANDS IN
EUROPE, THAT PEOPLE KNOW THIS IS
A FUNCTIONING GOVERNMENT.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
SO THAT IS A LOSS.
TO SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT, AND
IN THIS CASE ALSO SUCCUMB OF THE
SPEAKER DON'T HAVE THE LEVERAGE
AND PRODUCE THEY THOUGHT THEY
DID.
>> Laura: OUCH.
WITH BITE A DEAD PELOSI, IT IS
THE ART OF THE FAIL.
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE THE
HOUSE, THE SENATE, AND THE
PRESIDENCY.
BUT THEY CAN'T SHOOT STRAIGHT.
THEIR CONFIDENCE AND NOT AFGHAN
ARMY AND THEIR INSISTENCE THAT
INFLATION WILL BE TRANSITORY.
AND TONIGHT WILL ADD TO THEIR
NEWEST LISTS OF FAILED
PRODUCTIONS, THAT PASSING THESE
BILLS WILL SOMEHOW BE A LIFELINE
TO PRISTINA POPULARITY.
IF ANYTHING, WITH THE SPIKE IN
PRICES COMING AND THE DIMMING
POWER OF THE DOLLAR, BIDEN'S
NUMBERS ARE JUST GOING TO GO
LOWER.
THE NEWS WAS, AS USUAL, UNDER
BIOTIN, DISAPPOINTING.
THE FACT IS, EVEN AT A REDUCED
PRICE OF $1.5 TRILLION, A
STAGGERING AMOUNT STILL, IT IS
STILL WAY MORE THAN WE CAN
AFFORD.
WE ARE LITERALLY STICKING OUR
GRANDCHILDREN WITH THESE BILLS.
IT IS IMMORAL.
BUT THE SPINMEISTERS IN THE
BIDEN CABINET, THEY WERE ALL
HAPPY TALK TODAY.
I WAS HOWLING WATCHING THEM.
IT'S LIKE TRYING TO SELL SAND IN
THE MOJAVE DESERT.
>> THE PROVISIONS IN THESE TWO
BILLS -- OH, MY GOSH.
SO FANTASTIC.
THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT ARE NOT -- THEY'RE NOT DEAD
ON ANY OF THEM.
WE ARE GOING TO LIVE TO FIGHT
ANOTHER DAY.
>> WE HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS KIND
OF INVESTMENT IN OUR COUNTRY.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE FEELING LIKE
MAN, THIS IS ACTION.
AND REAL PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
FEEL REAL IMPACT AS A RESULT.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GOING TO
FEEL REAL IMPACTS ALL RIGHT.
ON THEIR WALLETS.
ANY SHORT-TERM STIMULUS FROM
THIS BILL WILL BE QUICKLY
DILUTED INTO SUPERCHARGED
INFLATION.
SUPPOSEDLY, THIS IS HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO PRETEND TO PAY FOR ALL
OF THIS.
A 15% CORPORATE MINIMUM TAX ALSO
APPLIED TO FOREIGN INCOME TO
U.S. BANKS, MULTINATIONALS.
5% SURTAX ON INCOMES ABOVE
10 MILLION, AN ADDITIONAL 3% FOR
INCOMES ABOVE 25 MILLION.
3.8% TAX ON ACTIVE BUSINESS
INCOME FOR HIGH EARNERS.
DON'T THINK FOR A SECOND THAT
THESE PUNITIVE NEW TAXES ARE
GOING TO PAY FOR THE LEFT A
SPENDING PLAN.
THEY NEVER DO.
IT IS ALL PART OF AN ACCOUNTING
GAME TO WIN OVER THE GULLIBLE,
SQUISHY REPUBLICANS AND MODERATE
DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
LOOK BEYOND THE PRICE TAG.
IT'S A STEEP PRICE TAG.
THESE NUMBERS ARE JUST EASILY
MANIPULATED.
BECAUSE THEY GAINED THE CBO
SCORING PROCESS.
WHAT IS ACTUALLY MORE IMPORTANT
AND FAR MORE DISTURBING IS WHAT
IS IN THIS BILL.
HERE IS A RUNDOWN IF YOU CAN
READ THAT LITTLE FONT RIGHT
THERE.
IT IS A MASSIVE EXPANSION OF
WELFARE PROGRAMS FOR UNIVERSAL
PREPROPAGANDA TO SUBSIDIARIES
EVEN WHEN FUNDING, THERE WILL BE
AN ENORMOUS RESISTANCE TO DOING
AWAY WITH ANY OF THESE PLANS.
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS NEVER DIE,
REMEMBER.
THEY JUST GET FATTER AND MORE
PERMANENT.
IN $550 BILLION ENDED UP GOING
TO CLIMATE CHANGE PROGRAM?
I'M SURE THERE IS NO GRAPH IN
THERE.
NO PAYOFFS OF THE NATURE TO FO
JAY.
FRIENDS OF JOE.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER WEALTH
TRANSFER TO LEFT WING ACTIVIST.
THEY WILL TAKE YOUR MONEY AND
GIVE IT TO THEIR FRIENDS.
BY THE WAY, INCLUDING IN THE
FUND IS UNDER $20 BILLION FOR
SOMETHING CALLED "GREEN ENERGY
AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE SUBSIDIES."
IT'S NOT EXACTLY CLEAR THAT OLD
JOE EVEN KNOWS HOW THOSE
CONFOUNDED THINGS WORK.
>> WE WILL BUILD OUT THE FIRST
EVER NATIONAL NETWORK OF 500,000
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS.
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YOU COULD GO ALL THE WAY ACROSS
AMERICA ON A SINGLE TANK OF GAS
BECAUSE OF THIS.
IT'S NOT GAS, YOU PLUG IT IN.
>> Laura: IT SOUNDS LIKE
SOMEBODY FORGOT TO PLUG HIM IN.
THERE'S ALSO $110 BILLION
EARMARKED FOR GROWING SUPPLY
CHAINS, BUT JUST FOR RENEWABLE
ENERGY.
>> IN A WAY TO GROW THE DOMESTIC
INDUSTRIES AND GET GOOD UNION
PAYING JOBS AND EXTEND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IS AS WELL
BEARD WE WILL GET OFF THE
SIDELINES ON MANUFACTURING SOLAR
PANELS FOR FARMS AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WITH TARGETED
MANUFACTURING CREDITS.
>> Laura: THAT'S INTERESTING,
BECAUSE HIS OWN ADMINISTRATION
JUST BLOCKED A COPPER AND NICKEL
MINING PROJECT IN MINNESOTA.
A MOVE THAT PEOPLE DESCRIBE IS
THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF BIDEN'S TO
LOOK ABROAD FOR OUR METAL
SUPPLIES.
AND THEN COUNTER TO HIS PRIVATE
COMMITMENT TO MINORS.
AMERICAN BLUE-COLLAR WORKERS ARE
GOING TO GET SHAFTED ONCE AGAIN.
BIDEN'S BIG PUSH HAS ZERO TO DO
WITH HELPING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
APPEASING THE GLOBALISTS AT THE
U.N. CLIMATE SUMMIT COMING UP IN
GLASGOW IN JUST A COUPLE OF
DAYS.
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THE SHOW HAS
BEEN WARNING ABOUT FOR MONTHS.
IT'S THE GREAT RESET PARED BACK
IN JANUARY, THE GLOBAL ELITES
WHO OUT THERE TOLD US WHERE THIS
WAS ALL HEADING.
>> YOU DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE STATUS QUO THAT YOU HAD
BEFORE.
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT WAS THE
STATUS QUO THAT GOT US HERE.
>> CAPITALISM AS WE KNOW IT IS
THIS OBSESSION WITH MAXIMIZING
PROFITS FOR SHAREHOLDERS.
>> WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP WITH NATURE FOR THE
SURVIVAL OF THE PEOPLE AND OUR
PLANET.
>> Laura: WAS THAT HAIR PINK
OR WAS THAT PART OF THE GREEN
ENERGY PROJECT?
THAT MEANS SACRIFICING YOUR
STANDARD OF LIVING AND
SACRIFICING YOUR FREEDOM AND
HANDING OVER MORE POWER TO
ECO-CRACKS.
THE CCP IS GOING TO BE PART OF
THE SOCIALIST ONE WORLD WEB OF
REGULATION AND RULES THAT
UNDERMINE U.S. SOVEREIGNTY.
CHINA DOMINATES THE RENEWABLE
ENERGY ARENA ALREADY INCLUDING
THE RAW MATERIALS WE NEED FOR SO
MANY OF OUR PRODUCTS.
THESE SOLAR PANELS, THOSE WIND
TURBINES THAT BIDEN WAS BRAGGING
ABOUT, THEY WILL ALL BE MADE
OVERSEAS.
AND ONCE AGAIN WILL INCREASE OUR
DEPENDENCE ON A MURDEROUS,
DESPOTIC REGIME.
HAVE WE LEARNED NOTHING FROM
COVID?
NO WONDER THE CCP IS SO ADAMANT
NOW FOR CLIMATE ACTION.
>> WE MUST BE COMMITTED TO GREEN
DEVELOPMENT AS LONG AS WE UNITE
IN OUR PURPOSES AND EFFORTS, WE
WILL RISE ABOVE THE GLOBAL
CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENT
CHALLENGES.
>> YOU KNOW THE TRANSLATOR IS
CREEPY SOUNDING.
CHINA HAS REPEATEDLY EMBARRASSED
AND OUTMANEUVERED THE
WHITE HOUSE AND NOW THEY ARE
DOING THE SAME THING ON CLIMATE.
FOR THE CCP, IT'S LIKE TAKING
CANDY FROM A BIDEN.
IT IS EASY.
EVEN IF BIDEN PASSES THIS
MASSIVE BILL, ALL THAT CLIMATE
SPENDING WILL HAVE ZERO IMPACT
ON FUTURE WARMING.
CHINA WILL MAKE SURE OF THAT.
IN THE MEANTIME, IT WILL BE FULL
THROTTLE BACKWARDS FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
WE ARE GOING TO GO FROM BEING AN
INDEPENDENT, ENERGY
SELF-SUFFICIENT FIRST WORLD
COUNTRY WITH A RELIABLE GRID TO
ALMOST A THIRD WORLD NATION
FORCED TO BEG OTHERS FOR HELP
WHEN WIND AND SUNSHINE CAN'T
SUSTAIN US.
MEANWHILE, OUR ECONOMY IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO STAGNATE OR EVEN
CONTRACT AND AMERICANS ARE GOING
TO SEE THEIR SAVING AND THEIR
INCOME ERODED BY THE RISING TIDE
OF INFLATION.
YOUR DOLLAR IS NOT GOING TO GO
AS FAR.
OUR DEBT AND DEFICIT WILL
FURTHER EXPLODE.
WE ARE GOING TO BE MORE SOFT
THAN WE ARE NOW.
THAT IS WHY DEMOCRATS ARE
PINNING THEIR REELECTION HOPES
ON THIS BILL.
OH, MY GOSH, THEY ARE IN FOR A
BIG SURPRISE.
WHEN AMERICANS GO TO THE POLLS
IN A YEAR, DO DEMOCRATS REALLY
BELIEVE THAT VOTERS ARE GOING TO
BE PULLING THE LEVER FOR A
STANDARD OF LIVING THAT IS NOW
LOWER THAN I